esta vez tenemos que f 2 es igual a 12
efe prima de x es igual a 24 entre x
cúbica y queremos saber cuánto valen f
1 muy bien así que nos dan la derivada
en términos de x entonces tal vez
podríamos sacar la anti derivada de la
derivada para encontrar nuestra función
original así que hagamos eso entonces
podemos decir que fx
efe de x va a ser igual a la anti
derivada o dicho otra manera
la integral indefinida de f prima de x
que es lo mismo que 24 entre x cúbica
entre x cúbica pero en lugar de ponerlo
así lo voy a poner de la siguiente
manera lo voy a poner como 24 que
multiplica a x elevado a la potencia
menos 3 esto
x y lo estoy poniendo de esta manera
porque va a ser mucho más fácil
resolverlo y trabajar con esto entonces
cuál es la anti derivada de 24 x a la
menos 3 bien solo vamos a usar la regla
de la potencia a la inversa así que lo
que vamos a hacer es tomarnos el 24 ok
poner x y después aumentar el 1 el
exponente me va a quedar menos tres más
uno ya está dividido entre el exponente
aumentado es decir menos tres más uno
así que esto me quedaría mejor como x
elevado a la menos 2 esto dividido entre
-2 y ya está
puedes ver que si llegamos a esta
derivada observa si sacamos la derivada
usando la regla de la potencia me
quedarían menos dos veces 24 entre menos
2 el menos 2 con el menos 2 se
cancelarían me quedaría simplemente 24
que multiplica a x ya este exponente
habrá que
darle uno entonces lo que daría 24 x
elevado a la menos 3 que es justo lo que
tenemos aquí así que lo que tenemos aquí
es fx viene fx tiene que involucrar una
constante entonces a esta expresión que
tengo aquí le vamos a sumar una
constante es que observa si tuviéramos
que sacar la derivada de esta función
bueno ya vimos que la derivada de 24 x a
la menos 2 entre menos 2 es 24 x la
menos 3 y la derivada una constante es
cero simplemente desaparece así que no
la vemos cuando tenemos la derivada es
por eso que tenemos que asegurarnos de
que aquí puede haber una constante y
tengo un presentimiento basado en la
información en la que nos dan de que
vamos a usar esta constante así que
permite escribir de nuevo a fx fx es
esta expresión que tengo aquí
efe de x
es igual y tengo 24 entre menos 2 es
menos 12 menos 12 x elevado a la menos
dos más esta constante muy bien ahora la
pregunta es cómo averiguamos el valor de
esta constante y lo bueno es que nos han
dicho que f de 2 es igual a 12 déjame
atraparlo con este color así que vamos a
escribir esto acá abajo tengo que
efe de 272 es igual a 12 por una parte
pero por otra parte tengo que es igual a
menos 12 y en lugar de x voy a poner 2
que multiplica a 2 elevado a la menos 2
ok esto más una constante
ahora cuánto es 2 elevado la menos 2
bueno aquí lo puedo hacer 2 elevado a la
menos 2 es lo mismo que 1 / 2 elevado al
cuadrado que es lo mismo que un cuarto
entonces en lugar de esto voy a poner un
cuarto un cuarto y de aquí obtengo lo
siguiente que 12 es igual a menos 12 por
un cuarto bueno eso es menos tres más
esta constante que estoy buscando y si
sumo tres de ambos lados voy a obtener
que 15 15 es igual a esta constante y de
lujo esto es lo que estaba buscando
porque entonces podemos cambiar a ésta
por 15 a esta otra sé por 15 y podemos
escribir a fx de la siguiente manera
fx
va a ser igual y bueno en lugar de menos
12 x menos 2 esto lo puedo escribir como
menos 12 / x cuadrada menos 12 entre x
cuadrada más 15 y bueno ahora quiero
averiguar cuántos efe - uno así que si
en lugar de x pongo menos uno entonces
acá abajo me va a quedar menos uno
elevado al cuadrado y brasil puedo decir
que en ft menos uno es igual a bueno
menos uno al cuadrado es uno así que me
va a quedar simplemente menos 12 más 15
y bueno eso es igual a 3 y ya con esto
hemos acabado lo que buscábamos era efe
de menos uno de brasil
podemos decir que este de menos uno es
igual a tres
y hemos acabado